all right do you or anyone you know have
a food allergy maybe it's peanuts maybe
it's shellfish
southwest medical wants to help you find
out if you're truly allergic
or have you outgrown it take a look
we're talking food allergies which are
very important to know and understand
about yourself and about your loved ones
so let's just start with the basics what
should we know about food allergies
well food allergies is more prevalent in
kids
and depending on the literature that you
read anywhere between
six to eight percent of kids would have
food allergies
and in adults that will drop to around
one to two percent
the most common food allergies seen in
children
are milk egg and peanuts and in
adults is mainly shellfish so if there's
a doubt
as to whether a test that was done
whether it be a blood test
or a skin test is truly clinically
correct or relevant
then an open food challenge can be done
by an
allergist okay so what is actually done
how does it work
well first of all we will only do an
open food challenge
if there are some things in question so
let's go back to the basics of
how do you first diagnose a food allergy
so a food allergy is diagnosed upon the
strength of a story
and i would like to really emphasize
this to our viewers rocky
is that oh we should not be testing for
food allergies
if you truly do not have a story
that is indicative of food allergies
okay
because the word allergy is very
much overused in some in some aspects
okay what do i mean by that okay
well you've all you've heard that people
are allergic to milk when they actually
have lactose intolerance
that is not a food allergy okay you
actually have people who say i'm
allergic to gluten
when they have celiac disease that is
not an allergy
so if you're negative and you want to
find out if you truly outgrown it
an open food challenge is when you come
to our office or an allergy office
and this is a standardized protocol
in that has been printed and published
by the american academy of allergy aspen
immunology
we will give your sister or any patient
the food in increasing doses
every 15 to 20 minutes if it's a low
risk we give it in four doses if it's a
high risk we give it in six doses
my message is if you truly have a food
allergy
do not take it lightly right okay
do not challenge yourself do not
challenge
with the food if you already know you're
allergic to it okay
stay away from eating that food
because one of the things that can
happen to you when you eat the food that
you're allergic to maybe nothing
but you don't want to take the chance
because the range
is from nothing to death is
so it's not predictable so because it
will depend on how much you've eaten
how it was cooked my second message is
always have an epipen and benadryl on
hand these are the things i would like
to
really emphasize do not do an open food
challenge
at home there we go we want to thank
southwest medical for being one of our
community pride partners las vegas now
we'll be right back